dans une campagne présidentielle il ya
souvent un troisième homme qui peut
renverser la table
le troisième homme le plus mémorable
c'est jean marie le pen en 2002 pour la
première fois le candidat du front
national arrive au second tour de la
présidentielle si le fameux 21 avril
2002 et quand on regarde les reportages
d'époque ce n'était pas tout à fait
prévu selon les derniers sondages au
premier tour jacques chirac arriverait
en tête avec entre 18,5 et 20% des voix
devant lionel jospin qui recueillerait
entre 16,5 et 18% des suffrages en
troisième position jean marie le pen
avec un score comparable à celui des
deux dernières présidentielles et les
sondages se sont trompés puisque jean
marie le pen arrive deuxième avec 16,9 %
des voix derrière jacques chirac et
devant lionel jospin qui se retire de la
vie politique ensuite au second tour
jean marie le pen s'incline et jacques
chirac est réélu facilement cinq ans
plus tard le troisième homme de la
campagne se situe au centre de
l'échiquier politique c'est françois
bayrou le candidat udf à la grosse cote
dans les sondages est à l'aune les deux
favoris à sa droite nicolas sarkozy et à
sa gauche ségolène royal cette dynamique
de campagne et tonnes et on parle même
de lui à l'étranger le nombre d'articles
qui dans la presse américaine
sud-américaine d'extrême orient se
multiplient sur ce qui est en train de
se passer en france
le candidat inattendu qui est en train
de bouleverser cette élection et ils
savent pas encore à quel point on va
bouleverser cet
électron au final françois bayrou n'a
pas bouleversé cette élection il arrive
troisième loin derrière ses adversaires
mais il réalise quand même un joli score
avec 19% des voix en 2017 il ya un
candidat qu'on n'attendait pas aussi
haut c'est jean luc mélenchon au fil des
mois il connaît une vraie dynamique de
campagne et à quelques semaines du
scrutin il peut même prétendre à un
ticket pour le second tour la révélation
de ces dernières semaines c'est le
président de la france insoumise jean
luc mélenchon qui remonte dans les
sondages fait un bond de près de 6
points en trois semaines et pour la
première fois fait jeu égal avec
françois fillon à 19% bon jean luc
mélenchon finira 4e aux portes du second
tour et cette année là le candidat
surprise qui a vraiment renverser la
table c'est bien sûr emmanuel macron
[Musique]